uh well thank you hannah very much i've
been looking forward to this event for
weeks we've got some brilliant
uh speakers and they've got very
different
views of the problems that we face of
gridlock the ones that you've been uh
hearing about uh i'm intending for this
evening's event to be feeling like
you're driving along in the outside lane
of an autobahn not that you're trying to
leave london on a friday evening on the
m4 so we're gonna have lots of energy in
the room do people feel energetic are
they looking forward to a bit of a
debate about transport is there energy
in the room
oh
i'm not sure i wasn't sure whether to do
this because i think you might think
i've been paid for it but i haven't
really i want a bit of audience
participation i was just thinking on the
way here because shell spawns if you're
over 40 in the room you'll remember that
a little jingle that went you can be
sure of shell do you remember that if
you're over 40. yeah it's very good okay
it's all i'm going to do maybe i just
decided to do this on the way here i may
never be booked again as a consequence
of this so on the count of three i want
everyone over 40 to sing you can be sure
of because you know how it goes and
everyone under 40 who's completely
mystified by the entire operation uh you
can shout shell if you're massively
green you can shout wind but shell are
very green anyway so uh on the council
tree over 40 you can be sure of under 40
at the end of it shell okay one two
three you can be sure of
one more time okay mommy council three
one two three you can be sure of
ah that's brilliant okay now we're all
there now we're in the mood okay now i
just want one more question i'm gonna be
giving i'm gonna be giving cars out as
prizes for brilliant questions and
points this evening not real cars little
tiny cars um so i'll ask a question
first album wall street the street we're
in now as it has a historic significance
when it comes
okay we're going to have a vote the
first vote of the evening my view is he
doesn't get the car because he
interrupted
so all those who think he should get the
car because he's clever put your hand up
now
all those who think he shouldn't get the
car because he's smart alec put your
hand up now
yeah unlucky um
okay so uh welcome to smarter uh
mobility um
we're going to be hearing as i say from
four uh great speakers and we're going
to be hearing uh he's going to try and
pull all this together the editor of
wild uk david aron who's a man who
describes himself as living in the
future that's fun i must ring you up on
a saturday afternoon when i'm betting on
the horses um he's well placed to
comment on the ideas we're hearing
tonight so he's going to kind of pull
this together i'm going to introduce all
the speakers uh as they uh come up
they're going to speak for only five
minutes which is terrible because they
could all speak intelligently for an
hour uh each and then after they're five
minutes there'll be opportunity for
about three minutes of q a it'll just be
one round of questions i've got those
little cars for clever questions i know
somebody who's not going to be called to
ask a question um and then
uh david will speak he'll pull it all
together and then we'll have a q a at
the end and we'll make sure that we
finish on time so that you can stay and
have a drink and something else uh to
something to eat maybe uh just a couple
of thanks i should thank michelle of
course for making this uh possible you
can follow intelligence squared the
organization is hosting this fantastic
event on twitter and tonight the
conversation online the hashtag is
hashtag iq2
that's the number two iq2 mobility so
feel free to tweet as we go but do make
sure your phone is switched to
silent okay so there we are um i'm going
to introduce the first of our speakers
he is professor paul newman he's project
leader of the mobile robotics group at
the department of engineering science at
oxford university
the team is developing a self-driving
car that interprets data from sensors so
it can see its surroundings and
negotiate them safely so please welcome
paul newman
thank you very much i think i think i
was always going to do this
i was never the guy that built the thing
that the lego box said you should build
okay i was always messing around i was
always going to be an engineer
and then something happened in my latter
days at oxford as undergraduate and i
realized it wasn't about the device at
all
that was a bit dull it was about
computing
there's something extraordinary about
the job that i have as a professor of
information engineering and that's that
we create a text file
that allows machines to understand and
move in their world and i expect never
to lose that excitement and i get a
chance tonight to spend now four minutes
34 seconds
telling you
about what we're doing with that on
transport it's not that i'm a transport
guy i'm not a petrol head at all i'm
interested in robotics and it's robotics
and information engineering that is
going to change transport have no doubt
so i'm going to talk about robot cars
what a great name huh so you know the
why the what the when and the how i'm
going to cover very very quickly if you
don't believe this you need to leave
okay this is i'm going to argue this by
assertion that always works i find with
undergraduates this has to be a true
thing i think to believe
that we will be condemned to the kind of
cause that we have now for all time is
insane okay it is much harder to believe
that we were forever driving than never
driving that's i think that's a that's a
bit of a truism so you know why do we
want that why might we want cars to do
some of the driving for us well because
you've all got 24 hours a day sorry
that's just fixed okay you just have 24
hours a day and we pack more into our
lives so why should you be slave to that
car in a traffic jam
efficiency we're terrible at driving you
kind of kill and maim and pollute i'm
sorry but you do when you drive you've
got to stop doing that and the cars are
going to help and of course the one we
always talk about is safety yes that's
great you know we want to do less
maiming and i think machines are better
at doing stuff than humans because if
they weren't we wouldn't have machines
so why we make them okay and why would
cars be any different they're going to
get better so the what let's talk about
the what about these driving so what
might a self-driving car need
well really important point
don't ask anyone to build anything for
you
okay let's not change the roads in any
way because we've spent our money on
infrastructure we built the roads we
took large parts of the country we
tarmacked it we painted it and we put a
lot of laws down about what you're
allowed to do and we built cities around
it that's enough infrastructure do
nothing else
so the cars must be self-reliant they've
got to use on-board computing to
understand the world and that's what
we're working on not reliant in reliant
have it if you want it but not relying
on external infras infrastructure like
gps which requires space rockets and can
be turned off it doesn't seem that smart
it doesn't work so well in tunnels we
shouldn't be relying on anybody else to
be self-sufficient i also don't think
we're going to be buying cars that have
a fixed competency like most devices in
the future they will be learning from
you they'll learn how you like to drive
they'll drive like you they'll like
learn to drive like the culture in which
you're embedded and they will get better
collectively over time because data on
how you're driving what all the other
cars are doing will be shared and
they'll learn and they'll get better and
that's going to be great they're going
to have huge memories which is free okay
that's an important point if you think
ahead communications memory and
computing is going to be done for the
transport sector by other sectors of
humanity that's just going to happen and
they are going to leverage it
so when
important line i think the cars are
going to drive some of the people
some of the time
in some other places and it's going to
start like that i don't see a tuesday or
a wednesday coming along where there's a
car that does you don't need a steering
wheel anytime soon what will happen is
the cars will offer you autonomy let's
say if you like in this traffic jam
you press this button now that's gone
green because you're being offered
autonomy i will drive you these two
kilometers and your insurance has gone
down by 9p because i bid for you in real
time and you go yeah i am a bit tired
and it is raining i take your offer up
and if it's snowing it might not work
because the conditions aren't right but
the car knows
the car knows what's safe and it knows
what it can do it's watching you drive
and it's rehearsing behind the scenes if
i was driving i'd be doing this yeah i
agree i could offer you autonomy and the
insurance will be real time it's not
you're going to phone direct line and
say insure my self-driving car for the
year please i think that's unlikely the
car will be saying insure me now for
this stretch of road
so how might we do we've got an example
car up at oxford the robot car and we're
a robotics group
and this is what drives us we're not
condemned to a future of congestion
accidents and time wasting we're not and
robotic science is going to fix it
really it's the roboticists that are
going to do this um so here you go
here's what i'm going to i could talk
for three hours at this point but i've
probably got two minutes i believe i'm
gonna 30 seconds he says here really
here is a way to do this so first of all
the car goes through and it memorizes
the world so it's driven by a human at
some point through the world and it
memorizes the world it builds a map of
the world this is horse guards we drove
through london one morning and it builds
a nice map of the world
and then at run time when the car goes
out with a cheap camera
it has that memory it has a memory of
all the places that all cars have ever
been driven and then cheaply with a
camera it can say well
i've been close to this place before am
i a bit to the left or does the view
look right i'm a bit to the right if i'm
here that looks just right i'm replaying
my memory and the car can remember where
it is and it can do this without needing
any gps whatsoever and if you've got gps
that's great but what we want to do is
have an arms race with the car companies
the cars are independently smart they
know where they are on the road without
needing any gps without needing any
fancy traffic lights with radio signals
and you especially don't need any built
highways because we've already built the
roads how daft would it be to say that
we just want to have an extra i want the
extra air conditioning when i'm buying
my new car i'd like the extra lumber
support and autonomy please it'd be an
option that you put in and that autonomy
ticket will get cheaper and more
extended over time so
we will teach the cars to drive
ourselves be like we'll be teaching all
computers to get better it won't be a
fixed competency and they'll share the
lessons collectively over all people
that are driving
and like all robots they'll get better
as we use them these have to be true
things because it's not just going to be
transport
all the computing that we use will
become personalized and better through
use
so the machines are coming
and they're going to drive us
if you want and if you're ready thank
you
paul that was fantastic was i the only
person who when you said a self-driving
car that drives just like you wanted a
person who thought of my partner and a
bit of terror ran through me um
uh anyway i'm sure she feels the same
way about me
yes exactly so um right questions uh
quick questions
ah very good there's somebody here tell
us your name and you've got oh well just
don't wait for the mic
yeah
gareth james there may be more and more
cars on the roads but as we know
more and more people are living in
cities is there really a role for a car
at all maybe we should be ignoring cars
and looking at other forms of
moving people around rather than a car
whether it's automated or not hold that
hold that thought okay where's the next
one yep go
potholes
there we are uh
yes
potholes you're getting a car um okay
and then there's a woman back there i
think yeah very good okay we'll just
take the where's it we'll just take
these three
hello uh i believe that we will have
self-driving cars when when does this
happen okay right do you wanna know when
you can actually buy one
yes yeah okay so so when can the lady
buy one
potholes and why do we need cars anyway
and hang on
okay so where's the car okay
let me take them in reverse order if i
can when will you buy them there won't
be
a sudden launch where there was a
tuesday where there was no self-driving
car on a wednesday where there was it's
going to come in slowly so some cars at
the moment the focus can reverse itself
and park you should look at the new
s-class mercedes the kind of
competencies that that has what we're
going to have the cars are just going to
get better they'll drive more of the
people more of the time in more of the
places this is going to be graded as it
gets safer as you get certification it's
not going to be a sudden market launch
of no need for a steering wheel you're
starting to see it now and it's never
going to stop potholes yes but why can't
the car see it
it's just
that's okay
yeah so you can see cause in fact many
cars will be driving with all the
cameras after 2015 every car in the
states has to be fitted with the camera
why can't those cars just be looking for
the potholes and say there's potholes
here why can't the highways agency on or
in every dust car have a machine that
goes through in fact we're doing this a
little parasitic device that goes and
maps the roads day after day after day
and you can see the potholes coming why
do we need cars in cities maybe we don't
but technology provides options it
doesn't ever force something on if you
don't want to buy a car don't buy a car
but if you do want a car with air
conditioning buy one with air
conditioning if you're getting old and
your eyesight's failing over time sorry
i'm not saying you are but
things that go wrong quickly um then you
should have that as an option technology
is all about options you might want to
buy yourself a green car knock yourself
out you might want to buy a car that
makes you less tired make yourself knock
yourself out it's a text file that you
can select on a tick box and say yeah i
do want a better car and it's
information engineering that does it you
know what i think if you ever became a
used self-driving car salesman
i think you do very very well let's hear
it for paul newman
okay so we've established the rule which
is if you ask an incredibly short
question you get a prize car um so
our next speaker uh who has flown here
all the way from boston robin chase
founder and ceo of buzzcar a service
that brings together car owners and
drivers in a car sharing marketplace
she's also founder and former ceo zipcar
you've heard of zipcar of course the
largest car sharing company in the world
and go loco an online ride sharing
community please welcome robin chase
so when i think about smarter mobility i
really am thinking about the future of
mobility and the future of mobility if i
had my druthers on the five minutes i
would tell you that the future is going
to be urban we know that 50
today and going to 80 by 2050 are going
to be urban it's therefore going to be
multimodal
because we can't fit the number of
people and cars as we have in cities
today and if we think of manhattan as a
very dense western city it is
in the density of cities it is not even
in the top 50 of dense cities and in
manhattan only 50 percent of the
households own cars so we're going to be
going to a place where 10 percent of the
households own cars it's faster quicker
cheaper it will be multimodal because
you'll be using the car that you want
for the each particular trip just like
in the morning when you wake up how am i
going to you know am i going to cook
myself am i going to eat it might need
it prepared you'll have this whole suite
and that is going to be the future that
i'll be choosing many many different
modes
and the vehicles when they exist will be
shared ones and we know that because as
we saw with zipcar that instead of each
person owning their own car we have one
car that's shared by 50 people
20 of those people were going to own
their own car and because of a share
access to a shared car they no longer
own it so it reduces dramatically the
number of shared cars in the future
there will be all shared cars is my view
definitely in the cities and we'll see
later i think elsewhere as well so since
i'm supposed to talk about cars
i don't think the future has a very
small place for the cars so what's
really interesting that's happening in
the car mobility sector is that there's
a new organizational structure that
partners institutions and big companies
that build a platform for participation
and then asks peers and individuals to
be co-investors in that business model
so if we think about zipcar owned and
operated its own cars and that meant
that zipcar would only put cars in
places where you get a return on
investment and i would never put a car
where i wasn't unsure of getting that i
started this company buzzcar in france
where individuals are renting out their
own vehicles and i think of this as
tapping into excess capacity and so
because it's people's own cars they've
already bought that asset they for
themselves if they rent their car one
time a year excellent they've been once
a month better and if they're three
times a day fabulous but because of that
that co-invest this coast
co-partnership
that i think of as peers incorporated
we now after two years in france have
seven thousand cars across the country
to be rented and we can have
transactions happen in places where you
would never have a car rental company
and never have a
a car sharing company because you
couldn't get the return on investment so
this is happening in many many different
places um the largest ride sharing
company in the world again excess
capacity i'm going from one place to
another far away and i have my three
empty seats it's called blablacar they
move um the equivalent
three million people i think every year
they move the equivalent of 2 500
high-speed trains every month but they
didn't buy a train car or lay a track
this is how we're moving people in the
future um sidecar
and lyft these are two companies that
are startups and san francisco
and they are you drive your own car as a
taxi as if you are a taxi so again we're
not buying any new taxi cars and these
cars it's just like driving your own
taxi
another uber is the same concept but
they're doing it two different ways one
if you're an owner of a black car or of
a tax if you have that kind of driver's
license through the app they take out
the middleman so it's a faster
connection again the company invests in
the platform and it's others who are
co-investing another example to go to
the developing world this is called
g-auto and it's in india
they the platform is that they created a
they do bulk buying of diesel fuel
they create standards of
etiquette for drivers they pay for
school fees and health insurance and
independent auto rickshaw drivers join
that company that's done all of those
things for them and again they've
created this bigger platform
so if as i explained this was the future
of mobility and i think this is really
happening
i want to close with the thought that
once you introduce self-driving vehicles
and i'm talking about fully autonomous
this whole world of transportation
is actually flipped onto its head the
reason why people um many of us take
public transportation because it's the
fastest cheapest best way and the reason
we don't take our own car is because i
can't park because it's expensive
because i'm gonna get stuck in traffic
and the but there's people who are
refusing to go there they're refusing to
give up their cars because they won't
participate in public transportation
once we have the autonomous car
there's two possible scenarios for it as
i see one is privately owned in which
case we are talking about transportation
hell
because we will have zero occupancy
vehicles that are driving around i'm
going to nip into the store please
circle the block 25 times until i bought
it or worse i want that pizza i'm going
to send the car and then some will run
out and hand it go pick up my laundry
for me that we will have zero occupancy
vehicles everywhere congesting the city
so i see that future for the autonomous
car
hell we need to have taxes and we need
to have strong regulations to make that
not happen conversely we have
future transportation paradise which is
they become public shared vehicles and
now i will i never wanted to get in the
subway because it was too crowded or i'm
two miles from the closest tube station
we'll be able to have door to door which
is the end all for transportation very
few people in that vehicle door to door
real time on demand and those cars will
be always moving they won't be parked
and if you want to share the ride you'll
be six people in a car and it'll be
cheap and if you are expensive fancy
person you'll say i want the whole thing
for myself and i want a mercedes but
both of these will dramatically reduce
the number of cars the number of parked
cars and that people are taking public
transportation that's everything thank
you robin
robin
fantastic i love the idea of the car get
me a pizza um
right so oh there's already a hand right
up there
it's the the little cars you see they
want the little cars and there's another
one down below is that oh very good yeah
thank you my name is alex shay uh
firstly let me say i'm a great fan of
zipcar i have a membership myself so
i'm all for that but if you really do
reduce the number of cars by a factor of
50 aren't you going to be the biggest
enemy of the automobile companies
i know ford i think are already an
investor in is it zip car
one of the car sharing so perhaps
they're taking a quite proactive view on
that but in the long term if they see
their sales dropping by 50 times
they'll put a contract out on you if
they think you're going to succeed right
okay there's somebody here
here comes mike
and then i'm going to take
this person right at the back there
because they're waving so much yeah i
was just wondering how you see the use
of policies which drive down car use in
the inner cities and how that has a
synergy with
you know things like buzz car
and car use i mean if you're going to
reduce parking in cities and that kind
of side of things i'm interested to hear
how that might operate
okay and then finally
uh how will the uh car sharing change
the actual design of a car
oh
you're getting the car okay
so uh are you going to be taken out by
the automobile manufacturers uh what's
the relationship between this and kind
of overall car use uh and what about
design
so when i started zipcar i did honestly
have an image in my head of the
godfather scene when people are going to
be dashing into my bedroom with machine
guns and kill me dead
um but now the car industry
through no fault of my own or through
fault of my own have actually seen the
writing on the wall every single major
car manufacturer has a car sharing or
peer-to-p car sharing company in action
and this is definitively the writing on
the wall and they're all scared to death
and they're working as hard as they can
to come up with a new business model for
the next 20 to transition to so i have
it's it's done it's going to happen um
the question about what does that mean
for my business model we have this
period of trans transformation and like
any company where we've stepped in to
enable this transformation and we're
always gonna have to stay on the front
edge and if it's not gonna be cars it'll
be something else but them's the brakes
today it's a huge market it will be
there and then as it fades into an
autonomous car has come
that'll be something we'll be providing
the software on top
and then the last question about this
which kind of cars to design i'm always
intrigued and i love this question
because i've been asked by car
manufacturers
what kind of car should we design
there's three points point number one we
have to disaggregate ownership from
access to the car and this has been a
huge challenge for zipcar and we had to
build their own how do you let people to
get in when they're authorized so that
they have to do that two they have to
have built-in car seats so that you can
up or down the for baby seats that's a
really big challenge and three
absolutely positively there is no one
kind of car the whole joy of having your
own car of car sharing is that
i choose the car specific to that exact
trip do i need a pickup truck for an
hour and a half do i need a minivan for
the weekend am i trying to impress my
boss let's get the bmw i mean whatever
it is it is profoundly not one car and
you think in that way when you think you
had to buy one and when you use it by
the iron by the day it's very trip
specific so i'd buy a car off paul and i
would definitely invest in any company
that robin set up robin chase
okay so now we're really going to take
off because our third speaker is jerry
sanders who's ceo of skytran a nasa
space act company which is working to
pilot a rapid trance we'd say pilot i
think that means pilot as an experiment
rather than pilot as a pilot
but to pilot a rapid transit system in
tel aviv a network of elevated guideways
transports people at high speeds above
the city using small computer-controlled
magnetically levitated unbelievable
jerry thank you thank you it is
unbelievable uh soon it will be
believable thank you
some people see things that are and ask
why
some people dream of things that never
were and ask why not
and some people have to commute to work
and don't have time for any of that we
call those people skytran customers
my name is jerry sanders i am the
skytrans chairman and ceo and thank you
intelligence squared organizers for
inviting me allowing me to address you
this evening it's an honor to be in this
august company indeed i even managed to
persuade my daughter to join me by
promising her that there would be movie
stars here thank you paul newman
several years ago i was approached by a
nasa software and biotech engineer dr
robert birch bob asked me whether i
could have an interest to take on the
management of a public transportation
company
well i was doing my best to beat a hasty
retreat from this mad scientist who in
silicon valley famous home of the tesla
and the testerosa trying to interest me
in public transportation bob opened his
laptop and showed me images of the
skytran system
bob hooked me then and i'm here to hook
you now indeed i'm here to show you how
we can go from not moving in traffic to
moving at speeds of 100 to 200
kilometers an hour above traffic and i'm
here to explain that we can do so
without stopping anywhere along the way
unless it's somewhere that we in fact
wish to stop
but first a word from our sponsor
congestion
congestion being stuck in traffic is one
of the most soul-crushing
stress-inducing irritating time-wasting
things that we as a society impose upon
ourselves and with great respect to my
colleagues whether you're in a shared
car private car electric car
computerized self-driven car
every vehicle sits in traffic
all vehicles add to traffic and all
vehicles cause pollution
yet worldwide anyone who can avoid
public transportation avoids public
transportation why because public
transportation is even worse than
traffic buses just like cars are stuck
in surface traffic they attempt to
follow and usually don't a rigid
schedule they're crowded during rush
hours
the time when you need them the most
subways your underground moves below the
traffic but it is certainly not private
and it takes a long time and a lot of
money to build
how much time and how much money well
one mile of new york city's lexington
avenue line was over ten years in the
making and cost two billion dollars a
mile
let's see just how bad it is
this is an illustration of traffic
worldwide i didn't choose just bad
cities i chose all cities
hope is on the way enter skytran
elevated high-speed low-cost silent and
unobtrusive green personal rapid
transportation elevated skytrain flies
above all surface traffic flies yes it
flies skytrain is a unique
velocity-based adaptation of passive
passive magnetic levitation to the
uninitiated that means that skytran
vehicles literally surf on a
self-generated magnetic wave using a
magnetic surfboard if you will and they
do so without generating harmful
magnetic emissions
high speeds how does 250 kilometers an
hour grab you skytrain is the only
system of its kind that can connect the
urban to the suburban to the x urban
unobtrusive sky trans guideways rest on
an 18-inch diameter standard steel pole
that means that it does not require a
lane in the highway a dedicated sidewalk
or an expensive concrete structure of
its own low cost skytrain is made in
factories like lego blocks and shipped
to the site skytran's infrastructure
costs are an order of magnitude less
than the cost of bespoke tailored light
rail systems how much less about 1 10 to
one twentieth less compare over one
hundred million dollars a kilometer for
light rail to less than three million a
kilometer for skytran
silent as in
skytran rides on a cushion of air no
rail on rail no rubber on the road so
quiet we have to put bells and whistles
on it just to let you know it's there
skytrain is green its vehicles use less
than half the energy of a hybrid car and
skytrain returns energy directly into
the grid without resorting to
inefficient batteries and personal just
get in and go no waiting on bus or train
schedules no stopping at other people's
stations no interest intrusive commuters
reading your emails in short there is no
faster more efficient or less expensive
way to reduce congestion and pollution
than skytran so when can you see it and
where can you ride it
well our pilot system what we call our
show-and-tell system will be built
within a year to 14 months at nasa and
or at israel aerospace industries we're
finalizing the details on that now our
first commercial projects are already
approved for tel aviv israel and italia
israel and we reasonably expect those to
be up and running commercially within
three to four years most of which time
will be devoted to addressing government
regulations and we also have a large
project nearing approval in kotayam
kerala india in fact i'm flying there
tomorrow for further discussions and of
course we hope that eventually the
innovators in silicon valley and
mountain view our hometown will come to
accept that public transportation can be
sexy too after all look at me
jerry that was awesome there's already a
hand up here
usually these are people who want to
come work for us yeah yeah
yeah michael hammond i'm just intrigued
what's the uh the the passenger capacity
of one of the units and you know
presumably that's one of the
restrictions yeah wait wait okay hold
that passenger capacity per unit there's
a gentleman there
so yeah my name is tony warmsley uh i'd
catch one tonight if i could uh what's
the singer's biggest obstacle
to developing it biggest obstacle i'm
desperate for a woman
uh oh not a woman
okay all right can you can you do a kind
of higher pitch high pitch yeah okay
good problem um just wanted to know
about the um energy
in and out of the system compared to an
electric car
please
right energy in and out of the system
compared to electric car
uh how many people fit in it and then
there was a second question
sure barriers oh yeah the barriers okay
so one um skytran guideway one line of
skytrain can carry the equivalent of
three
freeway lanes that means we can move
about 11 000 to 12 000 people
per hour per guideway line and that
means that the more guideway lines we
build we go up geometrically on that
um the second question was uh
barriers
barriers okay so i'm going to share with
you my favorite groucho marx quote
politics is the art of looking for
trouble finding it everywhere diagnosing
it incorrectly and applying the wrong
remedies
our greatest barrier is never
our greatest barrier is government
regulation
governments have a very hard time
understanding
what skytrain is and how it works and so
we find ourselves spending
huge amounts of time debating in the
departments of transportation whether
this is an airplane or a vehicle and you
would be surprised how much time and
effort and money is wasted on that one
question before we even get to build and
the next question and then the final
customers and energy emissions
competitive energy so
um okay i'll share another anecdote when
i joined the company several years ago i
was sitting down with these bunch of
nasa engineers all very smart people
obviously and they're explaining to me
how they've got this great system and um
and they use a power converter to take
um alternating current convert it to
high voltage direct current and then
convert it back to alternating current
and so well how do you do that say oh
just the power converter sits in inside
the guideway and i said where's the
power converter and they pointed this
refrigerator size thing and they said
that's the power converter and i said
well how's that gonna work so um we've
managed to shrink that thing down to the
size of a laptop computer it sits in the
guideway it takes alternating current
transforms it to high voltage direct
current and moves it back to alternating
current so we actually feed the grid
with electricity and each one of our
vehicles uses a third of the energy of a
hybrid car
very good now jerry this is a critical
moment
i'm going to either inspire you or
depress you i want everyone in the room
who thinks they will see a skytran
somewhere in the uk
uh during their lifetime to put your
hand up now
not bad not bad
and all those people who think it's it's
never gonna happen
okay that's not just because they're all
old to be honest um
okay jerry sanders thank you
okay so now for something completely
different uh we've we've got we're going
from high tech
i think it's fair to say to low tech
we're going from technology to people
we're going to hear from ben hamilton
bailey urban designer leading
international expert on shared space the
low-tech a-low-tech solution to city
congestion where counter-intuitively
it's a beautiful i love that word
counter-intuitively road safety and
vehicle flows are improved by removing
street furniture and traffic controls
he's the founder and director of
hamilton bailey associates limited
please welcome ben hamilton bailey
this is going to bring you down after
such high tech this is i'm
very very dull by comparison my job is
merely to beat up traffic engineers and
to try and find uh
simpler
ways of
creating civility because i wanted to
start by saying that when we talk about
smarter mobility we need to keep our eye
on what is it all about because
transport for what have wonderful uh uh
um
technology and business models and so on
you've seen but you remember that
actually transport itself isn't a good
we don't desire it for its own sake well
a few people do jeremy clarkson so on
generally it's a way of achieving
either greater
economic exchanges
or more social exchanges i.e money and
sex which is the things that we really
really want so that so that we it's
important to keep our keep our
mind focused on whether these solutions
give us more money in sex now because
ultimately what we're hoping to achieve
are successful
societies civility
and and and and and be able to
distribute and equalize greater wealth
now many people most of my life i've
been trying to find ways to reduce
speeds in cities because uh slower
speeds give you greater efficiencies in
cities and a lot of people talk about
in-house you know don't worry about it
because in in-car robots are going to
come along and sort the problem i've
always been rather doubtful about the
potential for uh allowing uh incar
rebels to take control of our of our
lives and i wanted to to really talk
about the fact that we often can lose
track of what we're doing in the first
place perhaps this is an unkind cartoon
but an awful lot of places start
becoming non-places because they're laid
over by engineers adding more and more
things and signs and barriers and so on
no doubt to solve good problems but
creating no places at all and if it is
an unkind cartoon this is the approach
into uh london from q bridge a hugely
expensive amounts of kit and technology
involved
on assumptions about the need to
organize the movement through that space
now
just one example of where this uh uh
been involved in in street design
thinking about what a street should be
the things that make up the huge
proportion of our both our highway
infrastructure our street infrastructure
our movement infrastructure and also the
important places exhibition road in west
london things you did don't know it
links all the great museums together
until a few years ago it was a pretty
miserable street itself nobody bothered
about that uh it's now been transformed
into a a street which still serves the 9
000 vehicles or so that move up and down
it at low speeds but it's also become a
very different sort of street instantly
when you're working on this i think this
is a street that challenges
our relationship between government
and cities and people because when we're
working on this the department for
transport as you you find out uh very
worried about the regulation what sort
of a street is it how are we going to
assign this to people to tell them how
to move through it and the cartoonist at
the time picked up on the idea and i
thought a very useful sign to to to
suggest it but it is it is the case that
for a long time we've been puzzled about
the relationship between transport and
public space i'm old enough to have been
at school when the department for
transport or mot as it was then ministry
of transport sent to every school this
leaflet about road safety uh the notion
that really children or people should
not be involved in the space between
buildings it should be for cars
and this is the poster that really got
me interested in this subject this came
out in 1981 extremely successful safety
campaign sachin sachi designed for the
department for transport which posited
this notion that really the
boundary between the carriageway and the
street is extremely dangerous i mean
even the americans don't kill people for
making mistakes like this they seem to
be a very odd image
so i've been looking for ways in which
we can we can rethink the nature of the
space between buildings and it's an odd
one when you think about it we know
we've realized in the last 30 40 years
how important our buildings are to the
quality of life and society and i want
you to imagine some nice building here
in london some
great building like this one or or
library or town hall and some vandal
some hoodie comes along uh in the middle
of the night and he sprays paint or
whatever they do that and the little
shit's dragged off to uh to the cells
but not before he's badly damaged that
building and the citizens wake up next
morning to find a nice building much
outrage and and concern the press
rushing and so on fortunately being this
being the city of london they're
extremely quick and efficient with uh
clearing up and cleaning up the damage
and carrying on the business of
responsible government as usual
there is an odd schism between the way
we treat one half of our public's our
built environment and another one i want
to touch on the work of this man uh
sadly no longer with us but he's a
traffic engineer you can tell by his tie
but he began to rethink the nature of
what how you can use cars more
successfully in the villages and towns
of his native fleece land and i was
fortunate enough to work with him for
many years and to stand on his great
shoulders and he began to take traffic
signals out at busy junctions this is
one of his in his hometown of drakton
where he handling a vehicle a junction
handling 17 000 vehicles a day very busy
indeed where counterintuitively the
removal of the
signal at the the the controls allowed
the junction become much more efficient
because as he always says people aren't
stupid if you try to do thinking for
people they become stupid don't let
people be stupid so we've just recently
applied to to uh solving the problem of
a small town in uh cheshire poynton a
place just south of manchester kind of
footballers wives country but it poor
point in the crossroads town has 26 000
vehicles a day going through it a lot of
them hgvs the middle appointment as a
result was completely destroyed and the
purpose of that little town was dying
because nobody wanted to come into
poynton when the middle of the of the
town looked like this
so what we posited was taking to our to
the amazement of the traffic engineers
taking out the signals
and everything else every other trace of
highway on the middle of this town and
allowing uh reducing speeds through
various tricks killing the drivers of
psychology and allowing drivers to make
up their own minds and i'm glad to say
that the congestion has vanished in the
20 months it's been operational we have
we've had one bruise knee so far
but the important thing is that
money and sex that many many more people
are coming into this uh small town but i
i as as as a boring traffic
nerd like me i love seeing it at higher
speeds because you realize how
remarkably intelligent uh drivers can be
simply given the right right cues so i
think that coming back to the question
of what is uh what what a place is about
well it's about that quality of the
church the the memory of buildings and
the ability to move around uh
simply and safely and interact with
drivers uh rather than have them uh sort
of hidden behind the technology of the
automobiles so i want to just finish
with the image for me what uh smarter
mobility really means it's a
an image of a place near here um seven
dials in uh saint giles near covent
garden and this is a as the name
suggests the junction which is very
complicated seven streets converge and
25 years ago the new the monument the
sundial was placed in the middle it
still handles quite a lot of traffic and
people
um there's always beautiful women
sitting on the podium because it's a
wonderful place to display your clothes
and so on but the thing about it like it
if you haven't seen and been there
before
is that it it's it's about life it's not
about itself about transport although it
functions extremely well as a junction
it has the lowest congestion rate and
the best safety record
of all of camden's junctions
but it to me epitomizes this notion we
call it shared space
of the idea of um
of simply the government setting back
and allowing people to be people and
that includes drivers who in in case of
seven dials becoming extremely hyper
aware
of an anticipation of the circumstances
and people around them does anybody here
remember faulty towers
you know old enough do you remember the
major in fulton towers well he's here he
comes now he's like 20 years older
but like
like most uh most people he can have an
odd senior moment and completely forget
what it was he came out for in the first
place
but it doesn't matter because something
about that space allows the
communication of human communication
between the taxi driver
and and the old man
which to me is actually what smart
mobility is about thank you very much
okay while we figure out with your uh
your mic we'll take three questions and
i'm going to take the gentleman there
with the kind of lighter gray sleeve to
his top yeah that's it
ian mcdonald i think there are two
factors that have been omitted slightly
one is
it's taken us centuries to develop the
car and the love relationship that we
have with the car is enormous
and we've got huge governments and they
basically exist in order to regulate
so things that you're describing seem
not to fit very well with those two
rather fundamental psychological factors
okay hold on to that point who's next
yep there's a lady hip
and a nice sparkly scarf
hi does it does does the concept of open
space which i love the idea of but i
know when i was in exhibition road i was
with lots of children and we were just
we were really confused whether it was a
pedestrian area whether where the cars
were supposed to be there where we
should park
does does open space like that increase
the anxiety and stress potentially
brilliant okay that's winning on the car
front at the moment uh but maybe the
third question will trump you okay uh
yes there's another idea can you reach
across the oh nicely done
okay
in fact 90 of a car's time is spent
stationary
um what does this solution do for that
oh
interesting okay so stationary cars does
it includes or reduce your anxiety and
what do you do about the
military-industrial complex and
you can share that with one of your
children another very good very good
question there i guess that reverse
order the the the the um the reason why
point and works and the congestion has
vanished is because
our journey times are determined by the
efficiency of junctions not by the speed
that we move between junctions and
junctions work much better at lower
speeds than the higher speeds we design
streets at for 35 miles an hour with a
30 mile an hour speed limit merely on
the whim of uh dr hor balisha the
minister for transport in 1934
who found it was the minimum speed that
his then three geared humber car would
stay stay in gear and not stall it's a
hopeless speed for cities so a
continuous slowing movement gives you
much greater efficiency of movement now
there's some other really good questions
here and of course anxiety does it
reduce or well that's an extremely good
question
the answer is if it didn't if you didn't
feel less safe i would be very worried i
would have failed
if you're interacting and moving amongst
half ton
lumps of metal moving around you should
feel a little unsafe and your children
should learn to be pretty wary of these
things so i'm very encouraged when
people say i don't feel comfortable or
safe in these surroundings because
that's a good thing it's good for your
safety and i'm very so i'm very glad
that you're less comfortable but in
terms of the the the military
industrial complex i can only say that
that the late hans mondeman said to me
early on ben never fight against cars
they're far too powerful work with them
because they are so embedded into our
economy and culture
that you will exhaust yourself swimming
against the tide that if you want to
find solutions you have to work with
what you have
what the technology will provide and but
also work with what who who we are as
humans to understand how our brains work
and the social
uh
motives that that we have as a as an
intelligent social creature ben hamilton
bailey
okay
so what's going to happen now almost
seamlessly is if the chairs are going to
come in behind me and we're going to
bring the panel up and david rowan is
going to try to knit all this together
as it's happening i've been thinking of
something to do with you there are two
moments of audience participation i
noticed in that session and this leads
me to a really big question uh you you
kind of went oh when you saw the
congestion but also someone mentioned
jeremy clarkson there was a little
freestyle so i'm going to ask you to
choose what's worse congestion or jeremy
clarkson okay so have a little think
about it um okay
we're nearly there all right all those
who think congestion is worse than
jeremy clarkson put your hands up
and all those things jeremy clarkson's
worth the
congestion oh i don't know it's quite
close quite i wish it would have been
slightly more definitive that okay
right panel do you want to come and
that's very good
yes very good okay i've got an image of
thousands of jeremy clarkson's ramming
up against each other okay uh panel come
and come and take a seat come take a
seat okay so now we're going to be
hearing from david rowan who's editor of
the uk edition of wired magazine he also
writes for the digital life column of gq
magazine and the tech traveler column in
conde nast traveler uh he has this your
task you know when you're on a road and
you're on the outside lane and you've
you've forgotten that your turning's
just about to happen and you've got to
somehow weave through all those lanes or
to get off of that causing an accident
your task is as hard as that to weave
all this together but it's up to you
okay it's up to you
you don't know what i'm going to say yet
no no
it's hard to follow some of these
rather clever people um so it's 1983
and you are the
ceo of atnt and atnt provides an awful
lot of landlines to consumers homes
across america
and then this new gadget hits the market
it's kind of
this big and if you're really careful
and you've got batteries that are
charged up you can make a mobile
telephone call with it
and you get early celebrity endorsers
like you know mikhail gorbachev will be
seen publicly using the mobile telephone
and
you start to get a bit worried
because you think hang on we have copper
cables going to hundreds of millions of
homes
and
this thing
may challenge our business model so what
do you do
you call in mckinsey you call in you
know the most expensive
smart kids in the world and you write
them a very big check and they go off
for a few months and they do some
calculations and you say to them um
just give us
a really informed view of by the end of
the 20th century and 17 years from now
how many of these mobile telephones do
you think they'll be in america
and mckinsey comes back and
is pretty certain it's got the best due
diligence it could buy
and it says well
we think
there could be as many as 900 000 mobile
telephones in america
by the end of the 20th century
um which wasn't a bad first guess except
there were 109 million
and
i think we can learn three things from
where they went wrong
first of all
all of us
tend to frame
our projections for the future based on
our
own personal experience and we take our
own personal histories and what we're
used to doing
and technology
moves in very different directions and
it also moves incredibly fast and it's
very difficult for us to see how our
comfortable routines will be challenged
by new things and that does happen a lot
if you think just if i'd come in here
three years ago and i just said
you'll be able to talk to this phone
and it will be able to answer back with
a voice
and then siri comes along and you get
into a bit of a habit you think you can
do it
um
the second thing
that mckinsey
didn't really put into consideration
enough was this thing called moore's law
which is that
computer processing power pretty much
through the last century has continued
to double every
year and a half year
and that's still continuing and
there's something
extraordinary about
exponential growth when things keep
doubling um just around the corner from
where
jerry is based on the nasa ames research
center is a place called singularity
university where
they try and prepare people to think for
these exponential opportunities and also
exponential threats to their businesses
and the simple way to look at it is
in an in a linear world where things are
increasing
one plus one is two plus one is three by
the thirtieth step you get to the number
thirty um but in an exponential world
where you're doubling the whole time
one
two four eight by the 30th step you get
to more than a billion
and we're on that path we don't yet know
which bit of that hockey stick we're at
when it comes to transportation
technologies but you have to expect that
what we can get from robotics from
artificial intelligence from other forms
of networked computing is just going to
be so radically different
just in two four five years
um and i think the third thing that
mckinsey didn't notice
was
it's not about technology
it's about
people and how they adapt technology
because it enhances their lives it gets
rid of the friction points it helps them
express themselves emotionally and
that's what the mobile phone does you
know you can see videos of your kids you
can buy a book on amazon by touching
once
and
in transport there are lots of friction
points so we heard about some of them we
heard about congestion um
but think about your own lives there's i
can't have another drink
i've got to drive
i can't go out on saturday night the
kids need that lift
and so it makes complete sense to me
that there will be massive
public demand for some of these
automated forms of transportation and
you know the self-driving car
is not going to be a fringe product
because all of us will find our life
simplified by it
it
will so was the hassle of having to find
a parking space
it will save the energy that we'd have
personally spent driving around
um
wyatt did a cover on self-driving cars
and the big sales line was
text as much as you want because you'll
be able to multitask
and
i actually think the cars could be here
a lot more quickly than we're suggesting
and you've got people like google with
these gigantic visions of you know
transforming behavior
and sergey brin saying well we could
have them by 2017 in some scale it will
take longer but
within a decade i think it will be
fairly commonplace
the other thing about exponential
technologies and the network
providing information to all sorts of
people so you get at our conference the
y conference two weeks ago
we had jack andraka who age 15 goes into
a science lab
and develops a diagnostic test for
pancreatic cancer he taught himself
which is 26 000 times
um cheaper than the existing test and
even quicker and just as reliable and
you know we're in a world now where
anybody can get
this information and make stuff
you can 3d print stuff you can get
access to factories um so there's going
to be a lot more innovations like
jerry's i think which involve
sometimes relatively untested
technologies
maybe maglev is the one maybe it's not
but there will be lots of attempts and
a lot of these will catch on there
doesn't just have to be one solution
it's going to be
lower cost for entrepreneurs to take
those big
risks um
again robin is right that psychology is
changing and the 20th century obsession
with ownership
as a way of showing status i think is
being eroded by
the sharing economy that is every like
you do on facebook and every retweet you
do and that
is
massively transforming the economy now
people are sharing rooms in their homes
with strangers on airbnb
and it was a niche a couple of years ago
and at the moment 140 000 rooms or beds
a night being rented out to strangers
now you could say rationally why would
people have strangers in their house how
unsafe is it if you're not there
but you develop a
trust mechanism um so i think
a combination of new technologies
um new business models and new ways of
expressing ourselves will catch on
and i also think it comes back to basic
human psychology we can very easily be
hacked we can be nudged if you create
a signless traffic junction
it makes us concentrate more you know
you don't need to be daniel kahneman and
you know have your heuristics list to
realize how
we're just pieces of software that can
be
manipulated quite easily so i think the
challenge for the regulators
is being ballsy enough to allow these
experiments then measuring the
experiments to see
what works and what can scale up
and if there is a
you know a fatal crash in one of these
experiments not to be
slowed down
in our willingness to take these chances
to try and build a better future so i
think we have to be an optimist
you have to be
prepared
for
a world where
maybe it's going to be drones that are
going to help transport us as an
entrepreneur i got to know he's trying
to build matanet which is the physical
internet with drones carrying goods
automatically they can go about 10 or 15
kilometers i'm trying to build a nest a
mesh network so you can deliver stuff to
african villages in the raid the rainy
season um
there are new ways in which
smart people
are coming from completely unexpected
places to solve problems the grand
challenges that competitions like the x
prize come up with and the darpa grand
challenges where the self-driving car
emerged means there are teams
who are not necessarily experts
who are
finding ways to do things that the
so-called experts would never have
thought about um
so
i would say that 100 flowers
bloom um let all these
potential solutions be tried
and
hack this audience's psychology as much
as you can because i think they'll be
the beneficiaries
thank you
okay so i'm gonna ask the panel all one
question um it's me really unfair
because paul is gonna have to answer it
first and you'll hear about it in a
moment and you have to think incredibly
quickly on his feet but that's okay
because you went to oxford
um and then when they've all answered
that question i'm going to open it up
for your uh your question so the
question
there was a famous survey done of um
uh professors in the 1960s i think which
were asked to predict the future
scientists they're asked to predict the
future and actually uh they didn't do
badly when it came to technology they
kind of got something that looked a bit
like the internet as an idea they had
various other kind of thoughts they
might have got to flying vehicles
slightly earlier than we got flying
vehicles but it wasn't bad
they totally failed to predict the
decline of the traditional family so
they did nothing effect they didn't
predict social changes so they got
technology right but they got the social
change completely wrong so i'm
interested panel in when you look at the
conversations we've been having what do
you think of the the social changes that
might be the most important ones driving
changes in the way in which we move
around in the technology that we use and
very unfairly unfairly paul i'm throwing
that first at you so um
this is untestable isn't it because
you're asking me to make a prediction
that you can't check right now so i can
say all things i think
i think something that's going to make a
very big difference
with
machines in general not just cars but
the robots that will be doing surgery on
you
the robots that might be helping you in
your homes certainly defending you and
driving you is data sharing
such that we should not be thinking
about single entities that act
independently but we'll be thinking of
entities that have access and we use
this word experiences the experiences of
all cars that are sharing data and
that's when they'll get good imagine if
you as a young driver
had instant access to every situation
that involved a cow in fog on dartmoor
and i bring that up because it was i
just passed my driving test
it took me six attempts and
did it really take you six to ten it did
because there was this issue with
getting reverse confused with forwards
and crashing into the test center wall
right
um
yeah so
and you know i i was on don moore and um
i made a mistake with the cow in the fog
um and
who came out a bit worse
which i think i haven't really talked
about much but i mean
if i had had access to every experience
of all drivers that had been in a
similar situation like a car might
imagine what could happen there now if
we start to say we're going to share our
driving skills and our driving ability
and all the things that have ever
happened and cars because everything's
connected because memory is for all in
purposes for all purposes
infinite there is no
limit to what we can store then i think
some extraordinary things start to
happen and happens in robotics as well
but we've got to allow ourselves to
collectively help ourselves by letting
go some of our driving so what i'm
hearing from that as a social thing is
that we think of cars as the ultimate
kind of acquisitive individualistic
thing you're saying that cars will will
not think of cars on that side we'll
think of cars as parts of a network
rather than i think that that changes
our relationship well you might you
might still feel you've got an
individual car but it's got access to
all the things that have been driven in
all driving experiences and then we make
ourselves robust because collectively
we're not bad
individually when we're tired we're
shocking so why don't we get rid of that
outlier of the shocking behavior and
have access to all the good things we
did when we were driving and now think
about that not just in cars think about
it of all computers and all machines
that will serve you and the world is a
different and exciting place robin what
do you think is the major
social change taking place in the
background that's going to influence and
change the way we think about transport
climate change
so i we haven't at all talked about that
and i don't even i can't couldn't look
50 years out i couldn't 30 years out 20.
in 20 years is going to be a
dramatically different world and i think
we'll have very different
priorities
and the
expensive jewel-like crazy whatever
we're not going to do any of that but to
his point paul's point it talks about
the beauty of the collective experience
if
my my optimism comes to part of that
that if i think of what we have to do in
the next 20 years
is going to
i think we can achieve it if we think of
the collective intelligence as in
building platforms for participation
where we can tap into
individuals unique spectacular skill
sets
and not everyone will be
coming up with that particular thing but
as
you know the person who is 15 who came
up with whatever i think in the world at
large is going to be able we will
hopefully be able to tap into
those amazing innovations and great
breakthroughs but i think climate change
is the single largest
anything that is shaping everything can
i just check one more question which is
i'm increasingly convinced that the
radical change is more likely to happen
at city level than national level
because city politics seems so much more
kind of dynamic and businesses and
political leaders work more effectively
together do you do you in your business
in this debate do you sense that it's
more at the metro level that we're going
to see innovation rather than national
level
yes
because that's where there's more people
one of the things about this collective
piece is that the power of people and
individuals being recognized for their
own individual contribution since
there's more people in cities
i would say that's the case but now
we're someone just got into mit i was
reading this letter that is from like
tibet
and how did he ever get here was he did
an online course he scored the highest
in this online engineering course and
they flew him in and said welcome with a
full scholarship
i might have that story slightly wrong
but it was a person from a dramatically
incredibly remote rural space so i think
it's the power of tapping into
individuals that we'll see and certainly
around politics absolutely we're seeing
that cities
are movers
jerry what do you think is a big social
change dad i am familiar with that story
and in fact what what turned out is that
it took that fellow more time to get
from logan airport to mit than it did
from tibet to logan airport
yeah
i think
to take um robin's point a bit further
it's asia the rise of asia because in
asia there is no infrastructure it's not
as though the infrastructure is bad but
if you travel in india india philippines
indonesia
um there simply are no roads and just
like
south america
jumped over the stage of the wired
telephone directly to cell phones i
think we're going to see asia
jump over private car use very quickly
because in china already they're
congested cities and you cannot get
anywhere to anywhere so i think they're
going to be the first adapters and we're
seeing it with skytran that they will be
the first adapters of this new
technology that allows them to move
because driving is not fun anymore
ben what do you think of the big kind of
so so i mean no one's talked about
population aging for example which is an
interesting thing as a driver so what do
you see as being the kind of big social
changes a backdrop to all this i think i
think there are two uh issues which um
are extremely important just to add to
the mix the first is the
realization of the potential for social
protocols to define what we do rather
than government regulation
and that changes the relationship
between the the states and communities
and individuals if in 1983 at that
prediction you you predicted well you
know but do you think by the end of the
century will be outlawed smoking in all
public buildings public transport uh
pubs clubs cinemas people say you're
crazy how are you going to enforce that
where do you find the police for to to
prevent that well we've done it and no
one in here would ever dream of lighting
a cigarette now there's no no smoking
signs not because it's against law but
because we've internalized and extremely
strong
i was actually involved in that
legislation that the law actually
but the reason that now it defines our
behavior is because of remarkable social
protocols that we're capable of
developing very fast the other big
change is that cities like this one
any market town like poynton or any
village is now redundant for the first
time ever in human history our markets
our towns we have no more functional
purpose to physically bring goods and
services together in one place the
internet or out of town superstores mean
that you can if you so choose not wish
to participate in the city the
marketplace of the city at all the only
reason that cities will thrive and they
will continue to do so is because we
wish to participate and to interact not
because we have to
and this shift from cities being
functional necessities to being optional
places that we choose
to interact with one another
has enormous implications for the way we
value public space
and the buildings and frame and the
stage on which we interact and i think
that that will be the biggest change in
the next few years thank you ben okay
i've got two cars left i'm still waiting
for some fantastic questions uh i'm
opening up what i'll do is i'm gonna
take five questions from the room and
then i'm gonna ask the panel to choose
one of those questions that they're
particularly interested in one or two
before we uh finish off okay i'm just
kind of like surveying the room i'll
take the woman right at the back first
thank you uh in
more developed economies the one of the
significant contributors to more
trafficking tell us your name sorry
mikael brack okay uh significant
contributors to
uh
uh congestion and cities as
delivery vehicles for all of our online
shopping so how do these solutions um
help to
help help with that and then in less
developed economies a big problem in
cities is just moving people around at
very low cost
um on very basic transport like buses so
how do these solutions help
okay so two questions in one one is kind
of delivery vehicles and the other one's
just about how do you make it incredibly
cheap for people who've got very very
little money so remember those two
questions there's a gentleman uh
there
second row from the back
good evening my name is amit as in mit
my question is smarter mobility
throughout this evening we've talked
about the mobility of people but what
about the mobility of the goods what are
the smarter ways of transporting our
goods which which is a larger part of
mobility as well good so that's kind of
a bit like the delivery question yeah
yeah good okay there's a gentleman there
in a blue
sky blue sweater i think
there it goes
here it comes not moving that quickly
not moving reasonably quickly here we go
great yeah
morris could there be a comment on is
smarter mobility less mobility
it's smarter mobility less mobility okay
very good and i took the lady back
there i should be choosing the most
awkward possible people for you i'm
terribly sorry
okay
motorists contribute sorry my name is
sarah i'm from the rac um motorists
contribute about 45 billion pounds to
the uk economy
how does the panel
um you know think that that's going to
be replaced through new technology
very good i think you asked that
question so you could get that statistic
in didn't you but no but you did it very
well very elegantly nobody would have
noticed um right there's someone right
at the back there with a pair of glasses
thank you
hi uh ravi gogna um you haven't talked
really about public transport and
alternative modes such as cycling and
that kind of thing um how do you think
that fits in with your smarter mobility
world
okay so so i think we've got kind of a
couple of themes we've got kind of
really cheap transport bikes and all
that kind of stuff and we've got kind of
goods and delivery as well playing
around okay uh what's who's next yeah
there's someone else in the background
just because you're looking really tired
um hi my name is joy tufffield and i'm a
cleantech investor
um a what
climate change solutions investing in
climate change solutions um
i'm fascinated by the sharing economy
but uh the question that i have is
is this is is the peer-to-peer
car sharing good and ride sharing in the
zip cars of the world is this a function
of
the the recession and people not really
having that much kind of cash at hand or
is it a kind of a shift a generational
shift in attitude to assets itself
yeah very you know if we're rich again
we all just kind of buy really huge cars
and yeah that's a really good question
okay uh and then there's a gentleman
there in the middle
so take a couple more and then we'll
come back to you pal
what do you think uh tell us your name
andrew haynes andre
what will be the impact of the changing
patterns of work on transport in the
future ah or will there be change of
power we've been predicting these
changing patterns of work for a long
time and they still haven't really
occurred as we know when we get on the
northern line in the morning okay uh
there's a guy there in a white top
with oars
uh jason lubbock uh you've all mostly
talked about kind of cutting down
driving
um cutting down the amount of cars but
what about driving for fun or driving
for passion or the love of cars that a
lot of people have
okay all right brilliant bit of a jeremy
clarkson question there and then back
nothing not there's anything wrong with
it and then to the back row there yeah
you're not sharing my bloody car that's
what he's saying right
hi my name is ben glatz i've got a very
short question do you think high-speed
rail 2 is smart
you don't have to answer that if you're
a foreigner because it's uh it's not
really fair on you okay and then i'm
finally yes you've got a nice smile
i'm not saying you two haven't got nice
smiles but he was just you know hi uh
pratik's record
uh my question is for the uh developing
nations where people are really inspired
to buy bigger cars fancy cars how do you
stop the inspiration the generation
that's coming up to adapt to the smarter
mobility
okay inspire that yeah very good all
right so panel you've got all sorts of
interesting themes i'm sorry for the
people i didn't i didn't call you've
only got 90 seconds each uh what i've
picked out of that is there's a
questions around
uh goods and deliveries and we haven't
really talked about all that kind of
commercial transport um i think there's
a rumbling around the room that has been
going on all evening which is
isn't it really that we just need to
travel less or is that you know
pie in the sky we're you know it's just
not going to happen we had the question
about is there ever going to be this
long predicted change in working
patterns as a consequence is that going
to be one of the issues that flows
into all this and we've had questions
about
how do we influence people in the
developing world and also about what
about the cheapest forms of transport
for people who've got no money at all
and cycling and all of that is a bit of
this story which is all about assuming
people have got a certain amount of
income i haven't probably covered
everything but you heard all the
questions so you can pick other thorns
if you want to robin i'm going to start
you just pick a couple of things
i'll go quickly it clearly car sharing
is clearly not recession-based since i
launched that company in 2000 and it
succeeded every single recession it's
gone through and grown
through all of them
um it's just smarter cheaper and better
uh do i what i what do i think about the
45 billion pounds or million pounds or
whatever that fact twice now
i i was in paris and i went to the sewer
museum and before they built sewers
there were 20 000 water carriers in the
city of paris who would carry water in
and water out are we sorry that we don't
have those twenty thousand jobs no
um the other question up there is
uh sorry will be replaced with something
else uh more massages and great takeouts
take a few i have no idea um go back to
the rac and tell them to get into that
there was another question of uh
uh just around trans uh freight it is a
huge issue and i'm not unafraid but i do
know because i believe that there's a
huge amount of excess capacity
in those delivery vehicles and i'm
certain that we could do a better more
efficient job better cheaper more
efficient job of moving that around if
we focused on excess capacity and made
people able to share that and i think
there was another car sharing question
that's fine that's fine that's great
okay jerry
i'll talk about the freight um fedex dhl
all those companies take more time to
deliver your package from the airport to
your city destination then it takes them
to fly it from wherever they're flying
it from to memphis or wherever else
they're going so it's actually that part
of the urban transportation that takes
up a lot of time clogs traffic causes a
lot of pollution skytrain addresses all
of that you could drop a package in a
skytran vehicle it would go directly to
your destination you don't have to fill
the surface with those big ups trucks
with regards to car sharing and
computerized driving i think it's
terrific i think clearly the younger
generation and else
and other folks in other parts of the
world but i'm speaking of north america
the younger generation is no longer
enamored with car ownership you can see
it people just want to use the car to
get from a to b they don't want to
necessarily own the car however
using the car
use of cars is rising it's not
diminishing worldwide the number of cars
on the road
driving congestion is all going up we're
not seeing it going down i think we're
reaching a tipping point and i think
that's why we will see more and more
alternative solutions to driving
very good ben pick our couplings i i
just wanted to come on the question of
is smart mobility less mobility because
it's an intro a very interesting
question and i think one of the exciting
things of our time and certainly the
last hundred years has been an awareness
about evolution and therefore who we are
as a species and our relationship to the
other great apes and so forth but
clearly
one of the uh the things that's
important to humans is exchange and
interaction
and by definition that means some form
of communication or mobility so
apparently only 30 years ago a farmer on
the eastern shores of iceland would
encounter in his or her lifetime 300
people
nowadays we meet 300 people in a week
easily
and the clearly there appears to be a
driving force both economic and social
behind hours to maximize your encounters
the intrigue the interest uh in life and
i wouldn't change bases without
icelandic farmer
even where i a very solid solid solitude
is monk
um but so i don't i think that we have
to accept mobility
as a
uh a human desire
but not for its own right but because it
allows us uh intrigue um un uh surprises
uh uncertainties it challenges us it
brings us in in contact with a greater
number of people
and that as um stephen pinker has so
articulately described recently it
reduces violence
very good okay
pandemics mean we're scared of leaving
our village because
nature tends to win um so we're talking
about the economics and we're talking
about environmental
reasons but there's a fundamental
frustration that more of us are going to
have
about
needless early death at scale which is
what we have
every day on our roads i don't know what
the figure in the uk is it's something
about 4 000 deaths in the u.s it's 34
000 a year sorry
one thousand seven hundred and sixty did
you get a car wow absolutely
i think a round of applause for this
absolutely
do you
do you work in this area
but a slightly morbid uh hobby i have to
i have to say sorry but if you think of
the
scale of suffering and family economic
loss by the injuries and the deaths
then it's a no-brainer to develop safer
technologies using data analytics using
very very low cost sensors using lidar
cameras which the automated machines can
deliver and it's
a no-brainer that you know government
investment goes into projects like that
rather than something like a high-speed
rail service that will be
technologically redundant by the time
it's built but it's led by politicians
who keep changing their minds and i
think the same
the same
shift is just look at what's happening
in health care at the moment so there's
a massive rise in investment in
innovative often digital health
companies because we now have
genomic science we have data analytics
we have portable very low-cost sensors
and i keep meeting very ambitious
start-up founders i met one on saturday
who says yeah my company's solving
cancer because we're taking information
that was in silos about which treatment
regimes which cancers were effective and
we're creating a massive public
accessible database and it takes a few
bold entrepreneurs and it takes you know
the elon musk trying to make electric
cars sexy or trying to come up with a
hyperloop idea um to solve these
problems which will benefit our lives
and our health at scale and i think we
can't argue with that and then finally
paul and then panel right at the end i
didn't warn you this horrible i'm what
i'm about to do to you i'm going to ask
all of you in a moment to choose one of
the other people to invest in okay uh
paul
you talked about you talked about cars
being attractive in the developing world
a car that drives itself is pretty fancy
so if a nissan micro could drive itself
because it's a text file in it that's
pretty fancy you talked about a passion
for driving great knock yourself out
enjoy it and when you're old expect you
still like cars and when your site's
failing or if you've had a fit i hope
you never do you must still like to get
in your car you took about 45 million
pounds for the rac great why not 60.
let's have more cars be more mobile
doing a better job you talk about moving
goods she prefers that to massager
have a massage while you're driving you
talk about you talk about goods okay
that is interesting um it's an
asymmetric problem we thought about
getting goods from the factory into the
vans
that's easy we can think about getting
the van to drive themselves
it will happen
it's the last 10 yards that's tricky and
every time the sainsbury's guy comes
right into my house i have my head on
its side thinking your job's really
pretty secure for now because i've
parked my car really badly and you're
lifting the bags past this that last
part for delivery for goods is quite
hard having said that people are goods
okay if you can it's just it's just a
payload you just wanted to go and do a
thing so there's a big big market for
smart's full stop for moving stuff
around and the machines are coming and
it's going to be good you need to be
ready
okay panel so this is your final unfair
question we've got here driverless cars
you can invest in driverless cars we've
got here shared car solutions you can
invest in shared car solutions we've got
here the weird floating thing
you know
you all saw it skytran that's the one i
knew that i knew that and here we've got
new urban urban design consultants just
kind of doing all that lovely stuff
there so you've all got to choose
you've got to invest in each econ invest
in yourself i'm afraid you've got to
choose one of one of your
panelists you're going to invest a
million pounds in david who you're going
to invest in
well i can't invest
because there's big well-funded
public companies that are going to try
and do the same things for profit
motives very quickly and i would have
invested in robin because she's got a
great track record as an entrepreneur um
but i think i'm as can i have a fund
that gives me a chance to kind of say
just chew
eight
it
can i can i kind of have enough fun to
back jerry to fail two or three times
before he finally gets it right very
good okay you're backing jerry all right
ben
what happened there i certainly i
certainly wouldn't invest in traffic
signals uh i have to say i i would i
would but i think that it's a no-brainer
that i would invest in robin not only is
she wonderful but she's a successful
entrepreneur and the sharing economy is
clearly uh here to stay very good okay
it's between jerry you won't vote for
tactically tactically who are you going
to vote for that's correct well well um
even though i still cannot send a file
from my mac to a pc
i will i will invest investing in poll
yes but tactically because i think right
so
robin you know i have to invest in ben
only because he voted for me no because
i think
enhancing the livability of cities is
going to be a major focus everywhere so
you're voting for ben right paul this
this is the crucial vote and i i'm with
robin for shared driverless cars very
good robin robin
robin
uh well it's been an absolutely
fantastic uh evening uh thanks to shell
for sponsoring it for intelligence
squared for making it happen thank you
to you for asking such wonderful
questions i got rid of
all my cars but most of all i'd like you
to thank our wonderful panel thank you